i'm obsessed with the truth johnny
depp's defamation trial against ex-wife
amber heard continues next week
slams me up against the side of the
closet
following a week-long hiatus et is
learning new details about what comes
next
the trial is set to resume on monday and
first up heard's testimony continues
which follows her shocking abuse
allegations
grabbed me by the hair
swung me around
after court adjourned last thursday
depp's team shared a statement with e.t
the attorneys say heard's upcoming
cross-examination will be most telling
and will highlight the many fallacies
they claim she has attempted to pass off
as fact in response a spokesperson for
heard slammed the actor accusing him of
attacking the victim and refusing to
take responsibility for his own conduct
then new witnesses are set to take the
stand with ellen barkin appearing
remotely in court depp and the actress
dated in the 90s
she was previously called for depp's
libel trial in the uk and according to
reports at the time barkin testified he
allegedly once threw a wine bottle
across a hotel room
another witness heard sister whitney
enriquez
i don't remember exactly when i met
whitney the first time
she's been spoken about multiple times
during the trial and now whitney will
appear for the first time in person
just last week heard testified she
allegedly punched depp in the face out
of fear he was going to attack whitney i
just
see my little sister with her back on
face
her back to the staircase
and johnny swings at her and i for the
first time hit him
like actually hit him
square in the face
he didn't push my sister down the stairs
and there's more to come from depp
himself i pride myself on honesty
following his multi-day testimony
heard's defense team is calling him back
to the stand
the ongoing trial will be in session
until thursday and picking up again the
following monday
[Music]